in his first public statement about the
murder of Saudi journalist Jamal [ __ ]
Crom Prince Mohammed bin Salman
acknowledges responsibility but
distances himself from the murder the
Crown Prince also known by his initials
MBS brushed aside accusations he
personally gave the order to kill the
journalist Venus ik
absolutely not this was a heinous crime
but I take full responsibility as a
leader in Saudi Arabia especially since
it was committed by individuals working
for the Saudi government Turkish
officials insist the killing was given
by the highest authorities in Saudi
Arabia the CIA concluded in its
assessment the order came from the Crown
Prince as international pressure on
Saudi Arabia piled up Riyadh put eleven
suspects on trial and find close aides
to MBS the trial is held in secret the
UN Special Rapporteur Agnieszka LaMotte
found out in her inquiry that the murder
was deliberate premeditated and
extrajudicial her report was dismissed
by Saudi Arabia the crown prince is also
facing growing calls to free activists
who have been detained for months one
such case is that of lagina have loool
one of the most prominent female
activists who fought for the right to
drive her family says she was subjected
to torture if this is correct it is very
heinous Islam forbids torture the Saudi
laws forbid torture human conscience
forbids torture and I will personally
follow up on this matter at the meantime
the crown prince faces more pressing
issues drone attacks this month targeted
critical oil installations had knocked
out five percent of the world's oil
supply the u.s. blames Iran describing
the attacks as an act of war NBS is
calling for a tougher stance but rules
out military option against Iran either
number human heart
if the world does not take a strong and
firm action to deter Iran we will see
further escalations that will threaten
world interests oil supplies will be
disrupted and oil prices will jump to
unimaginably high numbers that we
haven't seen in our lifetimes Saudi
Arabia also blames Iran for arming the
Shia Houthi rebels in Yemen more than
four years is the start of the saudi-led
military campaign thousands of civilians
were killed the UN says the humanitarian
crisis in Yemen is the worst in the
world first if Iran stops its support of
the Houthi militias the political
solution will be much easier today we
open all initiatives for a political
solution in Yemen we hope this happens
today rather than tomorrow but fighting
has flared up in Yemen dashing hopes for
any peaceful way out the crown prince in
his interview with CBS didn't mention
the GCC crisis at all the blockade
imposed by Saudi Arabia and his allies
of Qatar has led to deeper divisions and
raised concerns of further instability
in a volatile Middle East Saudi
authorities have recently announced
easing visa restrictions and dropping
strict dress codes for foreign women to
attract tourists and diversify an
economy addicted to oil many they'll say
these steps are an attempt by Riyadh to
rebuild the image of the crown prince
whose reputation has been damaged by the
murder of democracy and the war in Yemen
her mahabhava aljazeera washington d-c
the Turkish president Rajab Thai bad
ones written an article for The
Washington Post in which he says his
country will continue to investigate the
murder of Jamal kesaji
he says kesaji is killing was not only a
tragedy but also a blatant abuse of
diplomatic immunity noting that the
murderers traveled on diplomatic
passports and turned a diplomatic
building into a crime scene and were
assisted in the attempted cover-up by
Saudi Arabia's top diplomat in Istanbul
which set a very dangerous precedent he
goes on it's in our best interest and of
humanity to ensure that such a crime is
not committed anywhere again
all right let's go live now to Salem
Koziol our correspondent in Turkey in
Istanbul of course the city where
Jamarcus shaji was actually murdered and
President Edo are making no bones about
expressing how strongly he feels about
this particular incident as we approach
the anniversary of it calling it a a
serious threat to the international
order which challenges the conventions
that the world has come to take for
granted
exactly martin president arden
underlines that the skin this murder
could have been a precedent in terms of
diplomatic situation and or diplomatic
positioning which violated the vienna
convention mainly about his opinion i'm
and i must say that there is a softening
of his stone because last year after
this incident this incident happened in
turkey he he insisted that those people
who perpetrated the murder should be
extradited to turkey and those people
should be tried in turkey as the murder
took place on the Turkish soil however
in this opinion piece he wrote he
mentions that national course and
international courts can may deliver
justice and he underlined the friendship
between Turkey and Saudi Arabia is
stating that he has always distinguished
King Salman and his loyal supporters
loyal subjects and there's a difference
between them and the people who murder
democracy of Janardhan names them as
thugs besides his his highlight about
the abuse of diplomatic immunity he has
some other comments he's he criticizes
the court proceeding proceedings taking
place in Saudi Arabia he says that these
lack transparency these lack public
access to trials which it leaves a
question mark but he says we are friends
with Saudi Arabia and this incident is
not a another bilateral issue but an
international one that's why he believes
right now which is different compared to
last year that international courts and
national courts can bring justice but he
says even though we're friends we will
continue
to say the truth and we will be we will
be keep a we will be continuing asking
the same questions he says who where are
the remains of Jamaica gypsies buddy
who gave the order as Mohammed bin
Salman the crown princes say apron says
that he didn't give the order and and
also he asked who is the local
collaborator and who's dispatched those
15 diplomatic passport members to Turkey
so he will he believes that Turkey will
keep asking these questions but it turns
out that the messages the Turkish
authorities delivering right now are not
as political as before but more about
justice and international order and
sinem do we have any indication as to
how the Turkish authorities are going to
take their campaign forward which forums
will they be using in order to try to
find more of these answers to the
questions that so far still left hanging
in the air Martin so far the indictment
that Istanbul prosecutor's office was a
working gun was not ready I mean we we
were we were hearing that the indictment
was ready they had all the evidence
because we know that they have the
samples that they have collected from
171 specific points inside the consulate
we're expecting an announcement by
Istanbul prosecutor's office that the
indictment is ready and has been
submitted and so far the foreign
minister and Turkish president have said
that they have shared every evidence
they had with the Saudi authorities but
it seems if they will wait for the Saudi
national court procedures for now and
they will also they are actually a
wishing that the international
institutions are also the followers of
this for followers of this incident
because President Erdogan stays in his
opinion that the perpetrators should
receive the necessary punishment through
justice justice system as long as they
are not punished properly or if they
enjoy a full freedom back in Saudi
Arabia or anywhere else in the world the
justice will not be established and he
says that we
justice to Jamal Koscheck Janet's family
cinema Koziol ooh live in Istanbul thank
you very much indeed